so you're caught up on the attack on
titan anime you'd be a real
shame if a manga reader were to ruin
that
[Music]
doesn't every anime watcher love to get
the oh wait you're not that far yet
so you haven't seen levi have kids with
mikasa armin's gender swap and the
entire world exploding from a volcano
okay well i won't spoil it for you but
like it's crazy
and so you're probably thinking now yeah
i have had that happen to me
how did i get here to the point where
dudes reading books
have the power to ruin my enjoyment of
life well
that's the path that attack on titan
will inevitably take you on
you're either the spoiler or the spoiled
and alas
today i will explain exactly that the
fate
of every attack on titan fan and why
it's so
god damn miserable but also
absolutely euphoric let's get into it
[Music]
the first phase is what i like to call
ignorance is bliss
this is the time when you first start
the show and you aren't severely
depressed
yet that your favorite characters are
all dead or soon to die
that comes later you're just sitting
here enjoying the opening
watching armin cry every couple minutes
it's it's pretty nice
you're probably going to school and when
you do the pledge you just do the attack
on titan salute because you think you're
really zany and that it's cool that you
watch anime
you're not cool you're not unique
everyone's actually afraid to tell you
you're weird because the last time
someone did that you started screaming
sesago in their face and kept beckoning
aaron over
you know maybe i'm drawing too much on
personal experience here
no no no no
but you're a baby you really know no
better but
it really only gets worse from here
[Music]
phase number two the thumb biter you
went from sucking your thumb last
phase to just biting it now instead
trying to copy aaron's iconic move
by this point you've probably gone to
hot topic and bought your first ao
t-shirt
you probably also went on youtube by
this point and saw that classic video
god mode where he just straight
executes that one titan in the ova we
all know it
i've seen it many times myself i'm not
afraid to say
and here because of this you're starting
to develop this gross fanboy girl
relationship with levi because
he's just like way cooler than all the
other characters for no good reason
really
like why did isayama make him so much
better than anyone else there's nothing
to hate about levi
other than what he's too cool he's too
badass yeah come on
and this will only get more severe in
season three after you clean your pants
hearing him
shout kenny and then again proceed to
youtube to watch the levi shouting kenny
in six different languages that's in
everyone's recommended for some reason
and you've also probably got to the
point where you can't take your eyes off
the show
so you'll probably run through the first
season in the span of one or two days
phase number three is the you damn
traitors phase
this happens when you get to the most
epic moment of attack on titan honestly
where reiner and bird holds reveal that
they're titan shifters and
aaron just belts out one of the best
lines in the show
with just an absolutely stunning ost
behind it as well
and at this point you're also probably
wondering why yamir's titan shifter is
so
[ __ ] ugly when aaron's is this jacked
tank flipping rhino over with judo and
stuff
like she's just like crawling around and
like biting people
dude nasty
and at this point if you didn't idolize
aaron you're probably doing it now
you're one of those kids in his closet
practicing saying
every single night before he goes to
sleep yeah i do it too don't point
fingers
[Music]
phase number four the oh my god levi is
my favorite character phase
i mean everyone went through this after
season three you keep seeing that one
video about
animating attack on titan in your
youtube recommended because your phone
listens in on you yelling kenny
all day as you binge the entirety of
season three
now by this point you're not publicly
embarrassing yourself anymore you're not
doing those stunts in school where you
think you're cool watching anime
instead you're just a degenerate weeaboo
watching anime alone in your room
and by this point the best part is
you're probably going through mental
gymnastics trying to decide who the best
waifu is
the old but gold annie the everlasting
classic mikasa or the new
up-and-comer historia who just sliced up
her dad and showed the world who's boss
although that little rat titan has her
hands on historia so maybe not her
she also gets cuffed with a baby pretty
soon so sorry historia you had your
chance
phase number five the path to depression
you're not quite there yet but this is
where it really starts
after seeing the entirety of the survey
corpse getting executed at the hand of a
big monkey man
and watching armin get turned into toast
by neville longbottom
and seeing reiner get absolutely
beheaded in like a 20 verse one
like it just wasn't even a fair fight
like you're kind of happy that they won
and all but you're also realizing that
like wait so are we just killing people
off like that now
and yes we are and now this is where we
reach the point the single most
important decision you will make whether
you wait for season 4
or if you watched it recently bear
through the cgi instead
or resort to the manga make the devil's
deal and join the darkness that lies
between those two covers
i don't know why i'm making this sound
bad because this is what i did and i
don't regret it but
a lot of manga readers give us a bad
name like i swear for no reason half of
them
are just salivating in the mouth saying
oh just you wait till next episode
you're gonna love it diva goes crazy
like dog you could have just said
nothing man why'd you go to say anything
and why are you spitting in my face man
take a shower
monger readers and thus
phase six stuck between a rock and a
hard place
you're now on season four and you're
teetering the line between staying a
faithful anime only watcher or
going on any social media platform and
seeing spoilers and getting it
immediately ruined for you
or just succumbing and reading instead
you've really got no good options here
and on top of that aaron is like a huge
actual post time skip that takes like
the whole season to explain
and also big monkey boy isn't dead
potato girl is dead and gabby
isn't dead the survey corpse went from
cesagao growlers to
pervy ginger bowl cut losers like who am
i rooting for right now
i don't know also the previous aaron
thumb biters are re-questioning their
existence after seeing him shirtless
with a man bun in front of the mirror
and the people who were just thinking
about who their favorite waifu is a
couple phases ago
are now smacked in the face with peak on
all fours just to add icing on the cake
and in honor of the levi saying kenny in
six different languages by this point
you've probably watched peak saying
in six different languages as well
buenos dias
but you're also now missing the good old
days when you could just binge all the
episodes in one day
instead of having to wait every week for
some new scheme by everyone's least
favorite girl elena
and phase seven eternal depression and
sadness
whether you keep watching the anime or
suffer every week trying to avoid
spoilers or whether you decide to read
the manga
you're depressed either way and and
that's our fate
sadly you've watched one of the best
series to exist in the past decade grew
to love characters who are all probably
dead
and what did it cost everything
you missed season one when you didn't
know about all this genocide and war
business and it was all just about
survival
and eating potatoes during recruitment
with a nostalgic feeling
and then you realize this isn't real
life and just move on to this week's
episode of jiu-jitsu kaizen right after
honestly attack on titan not that big a
video guys
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
[Music]
you